The domain, in this case a, b, and c, contains all the values that we can input
into the function and get defined output values. Those defined output values are
the range. So, the range only contains elements that we get from taking elements
of the domain and mapping them over using the function. So, the next function
takes in the value a, it processes it, and spits out 1. So, a gets mapped over
to a value of 1 in the range. That's one of our numbers. B similarly gets
matched to 4, and c gets matched to 5. Since none of the elements in the domain
map to either 2 or 3, those two numbers aren't in our range. I just listed them
here, so that we had, a collection of numbers to go off of and have some
contrast.